-Our first guest tonight
is a Golden Globe
award-winning actor
you know, from movies
such as "Dune,"
"Inside Llewyn Davis,"
and the "Star Wars" franchise.
He stars in "Moon Knight," which
is streaming now on Disney+,
with new episodes
released every Wednesday.
Let's take a look.
-I wish I could just disappear.
I really do.
But, unfortunately,
I'm still here.
And if you are gonna
go through with this,
you've got to be smart,
at least for Layla's sake.
I've been in situations
like this before.
-So have I.
It's the same body, isn't it?
It's in there somewhere.
Muscle memory in that?
-Yeah. I'm not sure
it works that way.
Just...
-Oh, whatever.
-I'm here. You're not alone.
-I know I'm not alone.
I know I'm bloody not alone.
I've got Layla.
She's got my back.
-Oh, are you in love?
Now you're in love with my wife?
-I appreciate your concern,
mate, I really do.
-You lay one finger on her...
-But we've got it from here.
-...I swear to you, Stephen --
-That's what I need,
not a recipe
for a protein shake.
I'll call you.
-I'll throw us off a cliff!
-Please welcome back
to the show,
our friend Oscar Isaac,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Ah, it is so nice to see you.
-Thank you, buddy.
Thank you.
-I mean, from that clip we saw,
you got to live
a lot of actors' dreams.
You got to do a scene
with Oscar Isaac.
-I mean, it was the best.
-It was the best.
He's as delightful
as everyone says.
-So charismatic.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-So, you do get to play
two versions of yourself
in this show,
because you are playing
a character
who has dissociative identity
disorder.
-At least two.
-At least two, right.
-At the moment.
-I'm so careful,
when it's a Marvel property,
to have to stop
at the minimum of information.
-Mm-hmm.
-You know what I mean?
I would never -- 'cause
I just don't want to risk it.
-You don't want to be that guy.
-I don't want to be that guy.
-[ Chuckling ] No.
-But, you know, we heard there
you get to have an American
accent and a British accent.
Was the British accent something
that was there
from the beginning,
or something you brought to it?
-Yeah. No, it was,
when I got --
when Kevin contacted me,
he basically just sent
the first and the fifth episode,
and they were
early drafts of them.
And I saw that it was
set in London,
but the character
wasn't written as English.
And I asked
why it was set in London.
And basically the reason was
because they have
so many stories in New York.
-Yeah.
-And they didn't want Marvel
to just be New York.
The world is a little bigger
than just New York.
And so -- And so they
set it in London.
They just made him an expat.
But I saw an opportunity
to do something really fun
and kind of pay an homage
to all the stuff that I love.
Like, I was obsessed
with "The Office," you know?
I had, like, all the DVDs,
back when DVDs existed.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-And you know, so it just --
-It's a very bold choice
'cause, of course,
you were doing a British accent
and you're surrounded
by British actors.
-And the crew.
The crew is --
it was a large majority
of people from Budapest,
where we shot.
And you know,
London, like,
working-class guys,
which was great because I could
always go to them and be like,
"How would you say this?
What would you say?
How do I sound?
Does that sound okay?
They're like, "Yeah, yeah, mate,
it's alright."
[ Laughter ]
So, no, but it was --
you know, it's really
a testament to Kevin
that, you know, I kind of
came up with this voice
and I started finding it
and I would do it for my kids,
and they'd laugh and keep asking
me to do it over and over again.
I'm like, "Alright,
I'm onto something here."
And then I was like,
"Alright, Kevin, if I do it,
I'd like to do it like this."
And they're like, "Okay."
[ Laughter ] You know?
-That's the reaction
every actor wants.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-And so they went for it,
you know.
And afterwards, he's like, "We
weren't sure it was gonna work,
but we really wanted you
to do this thing."
And luckily, it works.
-That's great.
That's interesting
that your kids, like --
So, when I read books
to my kids --
and our boys are
about the same age --
they hate when I do voices
and they hate when I do accents.
Now, that just might be the gap
in our skills as actors.
-It might be that.
-Yeah,
-I went to Juilliard.
-You went to Juilliard, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You know what my kids hate?
When I sing.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
You have a beautiful
singing voice.
-I know.
I tell them all the time.
[ Laughter ]
It was my kid's birthday
yesterday.
He turned 5, and we got him
a karaoke microphone.
And I've just been using it
nonstop.
[ Laughter ]
And even this morning,
like, the little one,
the 2 1/2-year-old,
he's like, "Dad, stop, stop."
He started crying and crying
until I stopped.
-Do you think they're just --
that's the first moment
they've realized their dad
is needy for attention?
-Not the first time.
-No, they've got
a really needy dad.
-But, now,
we were talking backstage.
The last time I saw you was
the Thursday before you did
an excellent job hosting "SNL."
-Thank you, man.
-But there is something --
-You walked in
and wished me luck
when I was over there.
-I love to do it on Thursday
with friends hosting.
But you had -- you did have
a sketch that broke through
with the demo of 2 1/2 to 5.
-Yeah, and it's not
the one you would think,
'cause you'd think
it's the PAW Patrol.
-You did a PAW Patrol sketch.
-I did a PAW Patrol sketch.
My kids love PAW Patrol.
They weren't as into it.
-Yeah.
-They were like,
"Don't mess with
our sacred show."
-But they really Meatball Man.
-They loved...
[ Laughter ]
That's the only version
of me singing they'll take.
-Yes.
-As Meatball Man.
-There's Sarah, there, and
you are meatball on her neck.
This is a sketch really worth
watching if anybody missed it.
And you know, I realized --
I was watching it today.
Once I heard your kids
really liked it, I'm like,
"Oh, I bet my kids
would like this, too."
-Yeah, yeah.
It freaked out my cousin's kids.
They got really weirded out
by it.
But my kids -- my 5-year-old
just sang the whole song
this morning on the couch.
-Really?
-He already knows
"Meatball Man"?
-He knows the whole...
♪ I am little Meatball Man ♪
♪ Singing my little
meatball song ♪
-How can he say you don't have
a beautiful voice.
-Right? I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, this is, uh --
We're huge fans
of Ethan Hawke here.
And one of the cool things
about that --
'cause, you know, "Moon Knight"
is is a lesser-known property.
-But you knew about it.
-I knew about it.
But it's really cool because
it it feels like, you know,
not that there's anything indie
in the world of Marvel,
but it feels a little bit more
like indie and that it's you.
And then also I heard --
this sounds like the most indie
way to find a costar
for a Marvel property --
that you invited Ethan Hawke
to a coffee shop,
or maybe just saw him
at a coffee shop, and asked him.
-Ran into him in Brooklyn,
in our funny hats.
-Yeah, you guys were wearing --
He had, like, a what?
Like a fox catcher or something?
-Yeah. I just had
a big mustache.
-Yeah.
-No, kind of.
Actually, that's what happened.
[ Laughter ]
Everything about the way
this came together,
it just -- it ended up being,
like, the version of it
that I hoped it would be,
but was sure
that it wasn't going to be.
You know, I was sure
that I was, like --
I had all this good intention
I was just gonna end up
on a hill
somewhere in Eastern Europe
in, like, a cape, being like,
"What the hell am I doing here?"
[ Laughter ]
But, you know,
just, like, talking to Kevin
and then Mohamed Diab,
the amazing director, who's --
if you haven't seen his movies
"Clash" and "Amira,"
he's just
an incredible filmmaker.
And he's the one
that was going to, you know,
be the steward of this thing.
And we started talking about it.
And I was watching
"The Good Lord Bird"
at the time, and Ethan's
just incredible in it.
And I said, "You know,
this guy would be amazing
for this cult leader,
bad guy that we're developing."
And he said that he had been
actually working on something
with Ethan
and that we should do that.
And then, that day,
I went to a coffee shop,
and there was Ethan with
his daughter, getting coffee.
And I approached him,
and we talked for a little bit.
He didn't know who I was at all.
His daughter had to tell him.
And then -- but we exchanged --
-This is before Meatball Man.
Before you're a star.
took over the globe.
-Oh, yeah.
-And then we were like,
"Well, let's get together
and have a drink or something."
So a couple days later,
we went to Brooklyn Inn
and had many tequilas,
and I convinced him
to be the bad guy
in "Moon Knight."
-Very well done.
It paid off great.
-I mean, just that opening scene
in the first episode,
that's all him.
Like, he came up with that.
That's why he --
-It's a joy to watch.
I have a lot more questions
for you.
We'll be right back
with more from Oscar Isaac.